so i talked to like i mentioned offline
to joe rogan and his podcast yesterday i
talked to him all the time about this
i think the concern
is less about
the uh long-term effects
like on paper it's more about the
the ins like um
people like anthony fauci and
people at the top are simply
misrepresenting the data or like are are
not accurately being transparent not
collecting the data properly not
reporting on the data properly not being
transparent not representing the
uncertainties
not
us
openly saying they were wrong two months
ago like in a way that's not like
dramatic but uh revealing the basic
process of science when you have to do
your best under uncertainty just also
just being inauthentic there's a there's
a sense
especially with like a younger
generation now there's a certain way on
the internet like the internet can smell
[ __ ]
much better than previous generations
could
and so they they see there's a kind of
um
inauthenticity that comes with being
uh
like representing authority like i am a
scientist i'm an expert i have a phd i
have four decades of work therefore
everyone should listen to me got it and
somehow that maps to
this feeling
of well what are they hiding if they're
speaking from authority like this if
everyone is in agreement like this that
means they all have emails between each
other they said we're going to tell this
this is the message we're going to tell
the public
then what is the truth
the actual truth maybe there's a much
bigger uncertainty maybe there's dead
people in the basement that they're
hiding from from bad mrna vaccine
experiments maybe they're and then and
then that the conspiracy theories start
to grow
uh naturally when there's this kind of
mistrust of the that so it's less about
kind of
um
like a deep concern about long-term
effects
it's a concern about
long-term effects
if we find out that there's some secret
stuff that we're not being told it all
lands on that so what what the heck i
mean i so i put the blame not on the
data but basically on the leaders and
the community communicators of the
science at the top
well to that i would say
all the data
as far as i know are made public
so you can dive into it and i know a lot
of people ask me questions and i just
say it's right here
in the data and i know a lot of people
can't do that they can't dive into it
but that's one solution for people who
are able it's now you could argue well
maybe they've left data out well then
not even i can help because then they're
hiding it from me too and i think that's
highly unlikely i think for the most
part the fda requires the release of all
the clinical trial data right so okay
what so this clinical trial data that's
one thing so that's the data that we
should be focusing on right is it so
there's there's a lot of different
data sets here so there's pre-clinical
data which is
everything that was done in the lab
before this vaccine never went into a
human arm it's all the cell culture work
that we talked about a little
experiments in animals
all of that is publicly accessible most
of it gets published and then there's
the initial drug filing which is huge
the books of you can get that and look
at it right this is me sort of asking
sort of difficult questions here okay uh
so there is a there's a lot of money to
be made by makers of the vaccine
so
for these comp and obviously there's a
distrust of those folks too they've done
a lot of really good things in this
world but they've
there's the incentives are such that you
want to sweep stuff under the rug
if if you're not 100
pure in your ethics
and
how hard is it for for that data to be
fabricated
uh
manipulated like what's your intuition
for the the pre-trial stuff i think when
you when you start uh fabricating then
you get inconsistencies which are
pretty
easy to pick up when you talk about some
large-scale things of this nature
because then you can look through the
data very you're going to i mean we
require looking very carefully but you
will see inconsistencies from one trial
to another
and uh that may ring a bell that
something has been done
yeah
it's like it's like the moon landing
thing i think sometimes like going to
the moon is easier than faking it
right in in this sense it might be it
might be easier to do a large-scale
trial and get an effective vaccine
versus faking it but you know when you
brought up the for-profit issue i i
think that is always been
an issue i've always felt that
having your health depend on for-profit
industry may not be the best solution
and i don't know how else to do it
people tell me i'm a dreamer that
thinking that
you know all medicines could be
non-profit but i also think that the
world should have one health system that
takes care of everyone right because
there are some countries that can't and
other countries have an excess like us
so
i wish we could do that well the
argument is
the speed at which the vaccines for
covet were produced
would never happen
in a non-profit system would never
happen in a non-capitalist system oh i
could set up a vaccine production
institute in the u.s that would get the
vaccines done because you just need to
put money into it that's what made these
vaccines get done money they poured
billions of dollars and they got it done
quickly
but if i set up a non-profit institutes
of vaccines throughout the u.s staffed
with really talented people pay them
well keep them motivated you'll get your
vaccines no but this that's the thing
with capitalism is that
uh the selection of who to hire like
good when you say good people yeah the
capitalist has a machine that fires
people who are not good and selects
people are good
coming from the soviet union the dream
of communism is is similar to what
you're saying
broadly defined it certainly doesn't
work in the broad
the question whether it works in the
healthcare
space
you know
there is some aspect to the machine of
capitalism being the most effective way
to select for good people and to
effectively produce the thing and but
then of course
a lot of people would argue the current
even the current health care is not
with like regulations there's some weird
mix where there's a lot of opportunities
for inefficiencies there's a lot of
opportunities for bureaucracy so you
have like the worst of
all
can't there be some intermediate that
works because
i mean the other issue that we haven't
mentioned is that politics gets thrown
into this and nothing and that really
messes up and it should never be mixed
with health care but it's it is because
a lot of funding comes from the
government so that's another confounding
factor but i i i really think i could
make
a vaccine institute that
if someone didn't do well i'd fire them
no you're not going to stay if you can't
do your job and do it well you don't
give them incentives but it doesn't have
to be the two extremes i think it has
there has to be a solution that people
don't
have this mistrust for a company making
huge profits off of a drug but you know
what it's funny
it seems that vaccines and antivirals
bear the brunt of this criticism yet
there are many other pharmaceuticals
that people
rely on yeah of all sorts they don't
seem to question and have issues with
those and they have far more side
effects than vaccines it's very strange
however we're picking that way but i
should also say
that when you know if you have one big
uh vaccine institute one of the other
like
sets of uh
vaccine conspiracies
i mean i would say they're
a little farther out into the into the
wild set of ideas but it's you know
that's one way to con control the
populace
is by injecting
substances into them right people i mean
part of that
funny enough is probably has to do with
needles versus uh something you put in
your mouth yeah but there's something
about the government especially when
it's governor mandated injection of a
substance into you i don't it doesn't i
don't care what the science says if it's
100 effective 100 safe
there's a natural distrust of what like
even if this is effective
and safe
giving the government power to do this
yeah aren't they gonna start getting
ideas down the line for you know uh
i i think that they can barely govern i
don't think they're gonna do that but
you don't have to take
unless you're a federal employee you
don't have to take a covet vaccine right
yeah but that's that largely has to do
not largely but
there is an individualistic
uh
spirit
you know to them to the american people
there's this like you're not going to
take my gun away from me sure you're not
going and i think that
you know
that's that's
that's something that
makes america what it is it's coming
from the soviet union there's a power to
sort of resisting the overreach of
government that's quite interesting
because i'm a believer
i i hope
that it's possible to have
to strive towards a government that
works extremely well i think at its best
a government represents the people and
functions in the similar way that you're
you're mentioning but that like pushback
even if it turns into conspiracy
theories sometimes i think is actually
healthy in the long arc of history it
can be frustrating sometimes but that
mechanism of pushing back against power
against authority can be healthy i i
agree i think it's fine to question the
vaccines what i have issue with is that
many people
put out
incorrect information and i'm not sure
what their motivations are and it's very
hard to fight that because then it's my
word versus theirs and i'm happy to talk
with people about any of their concerns
but if you start getting into the stuff
that just isn't true
then we have a problem the thing i
struggle with is conspiracy theories
whatever language you want to use but
sort of
um
ideas that challenge the mainstream
quote-unquote narrative
given our current social media and
internet like the way it operates they
can become
viral much easier there's something much
more compelling about them sure like i
have a secret
that about the way things really work
that becomes viral and that's very
frustrating because then you're not
having a conversation on level ground
the
you know when you're trying to present
scientific ideas and then there's
conspiracy theories the conspiracy
theories become much viral much faster
and then you're not just having a
discussion on level ground it's
um
that that's the frustrating part that
it's not an even discussion
can i just say one more thing so i mean
the internet is here to stay so we're
gonna have to figure out how to deal
with it right but from my perspective i
was skeptical that these mrna vaccines
that any coveted vaccine would be
ready within a year yeah that's amazing
me too plus
these
the way i look at the mrna vaccine as a
scientist it's g-whiz to me it's amazing
that it worked and i looked i think the
data are great so i want it
well as a scientist i wanted one of the
really sad things again with me too as
a scientist or as a admirer of science
is
um
i don't know if it's politics but one of
the sad things to me about the previous
year
is that
i i wasn't free to celebrate the
incredible accomplishment of science
with the vaccines i was very skeptical
as possible to develop a vaccine
so quickly
so
it's unfortunate that we can't celebrate
how amazing humans are to to come up
with this vaccine now this vaccine might
have long-term effects
that doesn't mean this is not incredible
why um
why couldn't you celebrate um
because i would love to inspire the
world with the amazing things science
can do
and you know when you say something
about the vaccines they're not listening
to the science a lot of people are not
listening to the science what they hear
is
oh you're um
you're a republican or you're a democrat
and you're social signaling doing some
kind of signaling
you